oh my god
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and it's that
time of the year that day on my calendar
that i've learned to both love and fear
it's the annual pocky one chip challenge
and if we're gonna do the pocky one chip
challenge of course we need a guest and
i'm so happy to welcome back to the hot
ones experience wwe superstar sasha
banks side note hot ones legends
somebody ran through the gauntlet with
almost no problems whatsoever we'll see
if it's a little bit different today
sasha banks welcome back to this black
curtain box yay i'm ready i'm so ready
for this [ __ ] chat well today we're
doing something that nothing can really
prepare you for no amount of training
the pocky one chip challenge you open up
that coffin you eat that chip and
whatever happens happens they change the
recipe every year this is now my fifth
time doing this this chip this year it's
a mix of the carolina reaper and
scorpion pepper i've had both of those
as sauces before and those are no joke
yeah it sounds like it's not a joke
scorpion scorpion and the other one is
carolina reaper it's already hot in here
let's do it last year i did it with lil
yachty who actually tapped out on his
hot ones episode but then was brave
enough to take on the chip
oh
my god
after seeing his reaction how do you
think you'll do today it made me scared
but he also said he's never done hot
sauce in his life right
which is wild to me like how
never ever since then i think um since
i've been eating hot sauce every single
day anything's about everything spicy
every single day
i think i might have this in the bag all
right that foundational experience it
might come in handy here i think so are
you ready to unbox this thing let's
unbox it
all right let's open this thing up see
what's inside they send a whole kit over
so
you got a selection of pocky's everyday
lineup of flavors that looks good that
sounds good haunted ghost pepper salsa
verde my favorite i love this flavor you
have the uh fiery
chile lamone that sounds good
there's some scorpions in here i have
some scorpion toys okay for the scorpion
pepper
a headband
that's good for the flop sweat so this
is a spice veteran move where you have
the gloves as i often say careful around
the eyes because you can have that cross
pollination thing oh no no no no but
then with the gloves with these nails
too i'm saying oh my gosh
so they can't even get it on
all right doctor
and then the ingredients
the third one is fear yeah the fear
really comes through on this you know i
don't want to be fearful so
are you ready
they have scorpions on it i'm scared
there's no fear in me
to prep the taste buds they they
recommend that you that you try a chip
is there a flavor that stands out to you
i'm
i want to try this ghost pepper okay i'm
following your lead sasha
i actually love this chip i used to
search for it all the time at like every
um gas station
the haunted ghost pepper yeah it would
keep me up at night it's really good
there's a lot of spice on this one
generously seasoned yes but i like it
that way oh yeah
whoa
this one's hot
this one's good it's a hot one this is
like a head high yeah
i like this feeling
i think we're gonna break through the
ceiling though
okay if this one's that hot i can only
imagine i'm really scared for this one
chip challenge
i'm actually
really really afraid now so i take back
i am like fearful so i think it's about
time to take the plunge but before we do
that we have a message from hot ones
super fan brett baker who's actually
tried the pocky one chip challenge and
is going to give us a little taste of
what's to come so i guess we'll look
over at the monitor and check in with
brett
all right so here it is
the moment of truth
the pocky one chip challenge commences
now
come on
he's already turning red
i was thinking
oh no
good luck
make sure you have plenty of beverage
there
and uh
all of my mess do yeah see you on the
other side
my butt hurts
i know
no no no
oh this is gonna hurt
let's do it go in there again for brett
and you're taking the whole thing i'll
do it all right i'll do it too all right
let's pop this thing open
you have the chip
wrapped inside
all right pop that open hell no
oh
just off rip
so the way the challenge works is after
you eat it it's how long you can go
without reaching for a drink
that's the benchmark that's being set
so before we dive in they give you a
little uh they give you a nice
infographic on on how your performance
might stand up so
five minutes they say powerless 10
minutes powerful 30 minutes supercharged
an hour invincible
well there's no way i can last an hour i
know and i actually think five minutes
seeing what brett went through i
wouldn't call that powerless well the
high buy for for us is gonna be five
minutes that's a hybrid that's a high
bar
all right
let's start the timer
fire in the hole oh my god
[Music]
oh
five minutes might have been too long
no i can't even smell it i know follow
up
i'm down oh my god
i'm just trying to compartmentalize here
i'm hiccuping
i've got the hiccups i'm trying
to swallow it
oh my god yeah oh my god
i feel like a dragon one minute they
give us a one minute mark oh my god
you know in your hot ones appearance you
breezed through
and you answered anybody who would have
doubted you uh-huh
if you were to step into the ring
to battle the reaper scorpion dust
which wwe superstar would you want
by your side
oh holy
oh my god
how about
vince mcmahon yeah
can you handle it
i'm five years in
i don't feel like i have anything to
prove
two minutes
if it puts me in powerless it puts me in
powerless
no you got it
come on
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god
oh my god has anybody ever passed out
this is
oh my god
crazier than i usually feel on the show
i don't think anybody in the wwe can
handle this ten what nine yeah eight we
did it seven oh my god six mama five
please four thank god three uh-huh two
one
sasha
we did it thank god
no that made it spicier
milk kind of helps you
oh my
ill
i hate milk
yucky
any
important storm
sasha banks once again we shut it down
we closed it out oh my god and we made
it to the finish line
i don't know there's a pool of my spit
over here
to do the one chip challenge and
challenge your friends visit pocky.com
to purchase or to find a local retailer
make sure to follow
one chip challenge sasha ding ding ding
i think that's the bell
i'm giving up
you